Xuan to Sh CPU CPU to memory
CPU to memory
memory to memory
I wonder, do you remember the way?
Do you remember the way?
Do you remember the way back to Tarzana
Do you remember the way back to Tarzana?
Hello friends and welcome to the table tonight.
We are super just privileged and honored to have you here
and it's really a gift to be able to share this space every week.
This morning I was sitting in my bedroom
and I was just looking out our window
and we have some tall trees in our front yard
and typically during the summer it's just a canopy of leaves
but right now of course it's winter time and there's no leaves on the trees and they're bare
and it's typically not my favorite time of year.
I have trouble appreciating the beauty of winter.
I looked out my window and this morning especially was just a cloudy day.
It looked very gray and I was missing the sunlight
that typically pours in through my bedroom window in the morning
but without the leaves there I could actually see the sky
and I could see these clouds and in between the lines of clouds
it was just so obvious that the sun was behind it
and kind of breaking through these little slits
and you could just see it was just as if something was hiding it
and I could not help but in that moment think of how many times in my life
there's this feeling of like we're on our own
and it's hard.
Times can get discouraging. Life can be troubling
and recently that has been true at large in our society
and the world we're living in
and I took such encouragement from that moment because I just had this thought of
oh man for a minute there I thought the sun was gone.
I thought there wasn't any sun and then I had this visual
of where it really was like oh it's been there the whole time.
There were just other things in its way kind of distracting from its presence
but that actually didn't mess with the reality of the sunlight at all
and I just share that image with you guys as just a word of encouragement
that despite what things may look like on the outside
we are still being held and there
can be this fear that somehow God has left the room
at times when it looks so bleak or so dark or so gray
and I just want us to take this thought into the service
with us tonight that he is still here. He has not left
and he is still working just as much when it's obvious
and evident as he is when it's not so obvious and not so evident
and I just want us to cling to that together and really just
allow that to be a reminder to open our hearts and our posture
to what God is doing around us and to just ask that he would
awaken us and make us come alive to that reality.
So for tonight I think I'm going to save our
announcements and some of the details that are going on. We definitely want to give you details about the
book club that's coming up this next month in February and all of that
and I'll come back to that and we'll post links and all that but right now I just wanted to pray
and for us to be able to transition into a time of worship together and
we're going to let Mindy and Melody lead us in that but would you just open your heart with me
and let's engage the work
that God has for us tonight. God I just
thank you. I just thank you for the reminder that
you do not leave us. You do not forsake us
and that you're doing things even when we cannot see that you are always
actually doing things that we have no idea of that we are
completely unaware of. So God I just
cling to that truth right now and just
invite you and give you full permission
to continue working even now during this time together and
would you make our heart sensitive to the work
that you are doing and we thank you for the table.
We thank you for the people gathered here each one wherever they may sit right now.
God I ask that they would feel your nearness in your presence
and the hope that you are still at work. It's in Jesus name I pray.
Amen.
Hey table friends.
We're excited to be together again and
I'm Mindy if we haven't met and this is my sister Melody.
We are just jamming together here at our house and hope that you guys can join in
as we sing through a few songs but before we do I just
wanted to read a few verses out of Lamentations. I came across them earlier this week when a friend
posted them and I looked them up in the message translation and just felt like it was one of those passages that felt
so familiar. Do you ever have those where you read a verse and it's like yep yep I relate
I've been there I need this maybe I am there right now but
it was just one of those passages that felt hopeful and
just a good reminder that sometimes even when we aren't feeling it we can hang on
to times in the past where we felt God meet us or show up or
give us a picture of his closeness his grace his goodness.
This is in Lamentations 3. I'll never forget the trouble the utter
lostness the taste of ashes the poison I've swallowed I remember it all
oh how well I remember the feeling of hitting the bottom
but there's one other thing I remember and in remembering I keep a grip on hope
God's loyal love couldn't have run out his merciful
love couldn't have dried up their creative new every morning
how great your faithfulness I'm sticking with God
I say it over and over he's all I've got left
so we're just going to sing a few songs together and
we hope that it can create a space for you guys to engage
maybe with what God might be saying to you or encouraging you with today
I need you more
more than yesterday
more than words can say I need you more
than ever before
I need you Lord
I need you more
more than yesterday I need you more
more than words can say
I need you more
than ever before I need you Lord
more than the air I breathe
more than the song I sing
more than the next heartbeat
more than anything Lord as time goes by
I'll be right by your side
cause I never want to go back
to my old life I need you more
more than yesterday
I need you more
more than words can say I need you more
more than ever before I need you Lord
I need you Lord
so come and consume God all we are
we give you permission our hearts are yours
we want you
to come and consume God all we are
we give you permission our hearts are yours
we want you
to come and consume God all we are
we give you permission our hearts are yours
we want you
to come and consume God all we are
we give you permission our hearts are yours
we love you
and we'll never stop
can't live without you
Jesus we love you
and we can't get enough
all this is for you
Jesus
sing we love you one more time
we love you
and we'll never stop
can't live without you
Jesus we love you
and we can't get enough
all this is for you
Jesus
more of you bless me
more of you, more of you
Jesus
more of you bless me
more of you, more of you
Jesus
more of you bless me
more of you, more of you
Jesus
more of you bless me
more of you, more of you
Jesus
Come into God all we are
we give you permission
our hearts are yours
we want you
To come and consume God all we are
we give you permission
our hearts are yours
we want you
To come and consume God all we are
we give you permission
our hearts are yours
we want you
To come and consume God all we are
we give you permission
our hearts are yours
we want you
We love you
We can never stop
living without you
Jesus
We love you
and we can't get enough
hope this is for you
Jesus
We love you
and we'll never stop
we can't live without you
Jesus
We love you
we can't get enough
all this is for you
Jesus
Oh Jesus
Let's sing more of you one more time
let's sing more of you
less of me
more of you
Jesus
less of me
more of you
Jesus
ahhhh
Jesus thank you
that when we sing that God
it's not
it's not even hiding away
who we are, who you meant us to be
but living into
the fingerprints of God
in our life
living into the character
and the nature of God
that is already deposited in our hearts
God I pray that we
would be people who are
fully alive
God that we
would see ourselves
wonderfully and beautifully made
pinned in before
and behind
God and would you stay with us
in the good and the bad
would you be the constant
would you be the thread
would you weave us together
this tapestry of our lives God
even in our community
would you weave us together
would you make something beautiful
out of all these disjointed parts
God I pray that we would just
sense your presence in real ways
in our life God
not even just the glorious
miraculous ways that sometimes
we imagine God might be like
in the simple everyday moments
of your beauty
when we choose to be quiet and listen
when we choose patience
when we choose
the well being of our neighbor over our own
God when I take the time to listen to my kids
instead of getting frustrated with them
when I find you in those moments God
when you give us strength
to have ears to hear someone
else's perspective
and see it from their eyes
God when we find you in those moments
keep transforming us
into who you made us to be God
we love you so much
you are so good
we thank you for this time together
in Jesus name
amen
thanks guys
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
welcome to the table
especially if you are new here
we're so glad that you could be with us
so tonight we are beginning
part two in our series titled
epiphany a radical invitation
and the whole idea
of this season of epiphany
in the Christian calendar
is basically that it's a season to follow
advent so advent of course
leads us right up to Christmas
and advent
that's the season that's all about waiting
waiting for the birth of Christ
the kind of metaphor the image there
is receiving something from God
that we could not give ourselves
so that's advent
epiphany on the other hand
is basically an extended season of reflection
after Christmas
and it's a reflection on the story of the magi
who visited Christ as a child
and they were not so much
in a spiritual posture of waiting
instead they were
in the posture of going
of seeking out Jesus
and then worshipping and living
and loving differently
in light of that encounter
so that's the season we're in
and the series that we're in
so the title of my message
this evening is
the two scorecards
and we have a few scriptures
tonight that I'd like to begin with
the first is an ancient prophecy
about Christ
this is from Micah chapter 5
verse 2
and by the way there's a term here
that's a little bit strange
it's Ephratha
and that means fruitful
alright so Micah 5 2
but you Bethlehem Ephratha
though you are small
among the clans of Judah
out of you will come for me
one who will be ruler over Israel
whose origins
are from of old
from ancient times
the second passage
this is Matthew chapter 2
verses 1 through 5
after Jesus was born in Bethlehem
in Judea during the time of King Herod
Magi from the east
came to Jerusalem and asked
where is the one who has been born King of the Jews
we saw his star when it rose
and have come to worship him
when King Herod heard this
he was disturbed
and all Jerusalem with him
when he had called together
all the people's chief priests
and the teachers of the law he asked them
where the Messiah was to be born
verse 5
in Bethlehem in Judea
they replied for this
is what the prophet has written
that's of course an echo back to
Micah 5 2
alright so let me start
by just naming my
big idea for tonight
so here it is
the way of the world is
big people doing big things
in big places
the way of God is often
invisible people doing
quiet things in obscure
places
there is a famous story
from 1 Samuel chapter 16
that actually has a connection back to Bethlehem
so the story goes
that the Lord spoke to the
prophet Samuel and told
him that he had rejected
the current
yet soon to be former King
Saul and so the Lord told Samuel
to go to Bethlehem
to visit a man named
Jesse because
one of his sons would be
the new King so
Samuel makes the journey and
he gathers Jesse and all
his boys under the pretense
that he wants to offer or conduct some sort
of sacrifice and so the family you know
they know Samuel he's a very holy man
a famous prophet and so the family all gathers
for the sacrifice
with this esteemed prophet
but of course Samuel's mind
is anywhere but the rituals
and the
holy words for the sacrifice
his mind and his eyes
are evaluating
Jesse's sons
and the Bible says
that Samuel's eyes fell
upon Eliab
so apparently Eliab you know
he looks like a leader you know
some people have that certain
maybe it's a charisma or a charm
or that air about them that says
I will be successful at
whatever I put my mind to
well apparently that was Eliab
so Samuel's kind of scanning
all the boys Jesse had a lot of
sons so he's scanning all the boys
his eyes fall on Eliab and
Samuel sees him
and sort of whispers like this
prayer to God this kind of conversation
and this is what he says he says
surely
this is him
but then God speaks
in the quiet of Samuel's mind
and says this
do not look
at his stature
or his physical appearance
for I have not
chosen him
and then the Lord continues
with this beautiful line he says
man looks at the outward
appearance
but the Lord looks at
the heart
the Lord looks at
the heart what does that mean
it's saying
that we look to the
outer person and I'm
going to take that more than just literally
their faces or something but it's
I mean it is it could be their faces
their bodies their clothes
their hair but also things like their
status
their location in the
social hierarchy this is what
we do it's quite instinctive
we do it without thinking
we are all natural born judgers
anyone who says
I'm not really a judgmental person
yeah your line
we are all judgmental we all
make snap decisions about people
I mean within seconds we've like evaluated
them and kind of categorized
and ranked them
and kind of know like okay is this someone I need to like
kind of defer to here
or am I you know this is like we're always
we're always doing this
and that's what it means to look at the
outward appearance
but apparently God does not
see like we
see when God
looks at us
he does not see our net worth
our rank at work
our GPA
the fancy
or not so fancy neighborhood we live
in God doesn't see what
others say about us
the awards the trophies
the status symbols
we have wound around
ourselves God
doesn't look to the outer
person where does God look? God looks
straight to the inner person
it's what today we would
call maybe the soul
have you ever known someone of great
love of great character
someone who you just knew had a certain
depth dimension in them
a rootedness a
humility a quiet strength
and you just knew
it had grown from
their connection to God
if so
then you have some idea
of what it is God
is seeing how it is
God sees
see the way of the world
is big people doing big things
in big places the way
of God is often
not always but often
invisible people doing
quiet things in
obscure places
here's another story
about Bethlehem there were
these magi these
pagan magicians
these astrologers watchers
of the stars and
they discerned the sign
it was this new star
in the sky leading
them west
and so on and on and on
they journeyed for weeks
perhaps months seeking
this new king of the Jews
this baby that they
somehow knew would be one of
if not the single most significant people
ever to be born and the whole
time they're following this
star now I've never navigated
by the stars I'm just
more of a Google Maps guy but
I imagine
it's not like a precise science
I imagine it's more
kind of okay
I'm headed in the
right direction like generally
of whatever I'm seeking
which is why these wizards
they can be forgiven for being off
by 9 miles
did you catch that they were off?
where did they go first?
let's take another look this is our
text this is verse 1 and 2
of Matthew chapter 2
after Jesus was born in Bethlehem
in the kind of
region of Judea during the
time of King Herod magi from the
east came to where?
Jerusalem
so he's born in Bethlehem
and they went to Jerusalem
and then they get there and they ask
uh
where is he?
where's the one who has been
born king of the Jews? we saw his star
when it rose and we're here
we have come to worship him
so what's going on? you see these magi
they went to the place that
anyone in their right mind
seeking the new king of the Jews would go
Jerusalem
they went to the big city
with it's big people
doing big things
but they were wrong
they were wrong by 9 miles
Jesus was born
in rural
dusty
unpretentious Bethlehem
and it's ancient location
was 9 miles south of
Jerusalem which is why the magi
can be forgiven I mean if you're
following the star again you're
probably lining it up and you're
saying okay so Jerusalem
looks slightly off from where
the star is pointing but
I mean surely
right fellas?
it's gotta be
and I imagine like if this took place in our
kind of day and age and the magi they would be following
the star towards Dallas and they get close
and they're like it almost looks like
it's pointing to
sexy
that can't be right
it's gotta be Dallas the big city
what was happening?
they were seeing the way human beings see
they're interpreting the way human beings
interpret they're looking for an amazing
person
and so they go to the nearest amazing
place
because the way of the world
is big people doing big things
in big places
and of course it's not just them it's not just
the magi or Samuel the prophet
what do we do? what do we assume?
we assume that
because this is how the world
works then God must
work the same way too
we assume that
God sees how we
see
this is actually one reason
that I just
find the Christian story so compelling
and so beautiful because it's
just not the way human
beings left to their own devices would write
the story it's too
upside down it cuts against
the grain of everything
we stand for
especially in Texas we like big
big people doing big things in big
places and by
the way saying
I'm a Christian or I'm a spiritual person
that's
like not the hard part
like buying a Hyundai
and then swapping out the hood ornament
for a BMW logo
you might fool people
like me who don't know their cars
but a knowledgeable person is
definitely going to see through that
no no no what's much harder
is to have a clunker
and then go through the painstaking
process of rebuilding
the engine
and that's what true Christian spirituality
is all about Christ is not
interested in you and I slapping
a Jesus hood ornament on the
car of our metaphorical
life he's interested
in rebuilding the engine
you say what do you mean by the
engine I mean the inside of us
our motivations our
values our desires
our loves who we love
how we love he did not come
to give us cosmetic surgery
to pretty us up on the
outside he came as the great physician
offering all
of humanity heart surgery
surgery soul
surgery this is what being
a Christian is it's signing up for the
difficult process of having
our absolute obsession
with being externally
bigger and better and
greater and
it's having all of that turned
upside down
or perhaps I should say inside
out because we go
from being obsessed
with becoming better
out there
in this kind of in the outward
appearances to slowly
becoming obsessed
with who we are becoming
in here
the way
that Jesus put it once
he said this what good is it
if you gain the whole world
but lose your
soul
that's what Jesus is all about
not who you are on the outside
remember we look at the outward
appearance where does God look
at the heart so his question
is who are you becoming
on the inside
are you more patient
than you were a year ago
are you more honest
more courageous
more kind
I listened to an interview recently
with Dr. Jim
Layer he is a performance
psychologist who has worked with hundreds
of the best just the best athletes
in the world across like a variety
of sports from tennis
basketball golf to even Olympians
and not only
has he worked with like people in these domains
but he's worked with like the
best of the best we're talking like
Olympic gold medalists
even in tennis
he's worked with Roger Federer and
Monica Sellis who both have been number
one in their respective
kind of
in tennis
these are like big people big names
but he noticed a trend
and he described it
this way he said that he worked with people
who reached the top of their field
and they would have
conversations with him
after they won the big match
of the game and now they were
you know Super Bowl champion
or NBA champion or gold medalist
and they would meet with him
because he was their performance
psychologist and they would meet with him
afterwards and they would
say something like this
I don't
feel any different
like
I thought I would feel
complete
somehow at peace
like this has been my dream for so long
and now I'm here
and it's all
sort of empty
but then
Dr. Laird said he would talk with other people
who also reached the top
of their field but they were
so happy
but he noticed they were happy before
they became number one
or Olympic champion or whatever
and so he became
quite obsessed with
figuring out
well why on earth
like how is it that people
could end up in these
two very different places
and eventually he figured it
out and this is what he said
he said I came to understand
that we all
all human beings
we all have two
scorecards
the first scorecard is about
our outward success
and
that's where society tells us to focus
but there
is a second scorecard
and it's
actually the more important scorecard
the second scorecard is an
internal scorecard
and it's about
our character
what kind of people
are we becoming
he said the first group
the unhappy group
they were more inclined he found
to ignore
or even sacrifice
who they were from an integrity
and character standpoint
in order to make it
to the top of the first scorecard
in other words they were going to get
to the top regardless of whether or not
they had to lie, cheat, tear
others down on their way up like whatever it took
whereas the second group
they had such joy
because they were winning
on their own
internal character
scorecard which meant
they could be at peace
with whatever happened externally
and so I'm listening
to this interview with Dr. Lair
and I'm just thinking to myself
my goodness this is what the bible has been
naming I mean think back to our text
man looks at
scorecard number one
the outward scorecard
but God
looks at the
inner scorecard
or think back to Jesus quote what good is it
to climb to the tippy top
of scorecard number one
but to be the worst
kind of failure
at scorecard number
two right gaining the
whole world losing the
soul you see the way of the world is
an obsession with the first
scorecard but the path
of Christ
it's a switch
it is a new orientation
towards the second
scorecard
it's a new orientation
towards who we are becoming
who we are becoming on the
inside right
our character our integrity
our love it's what has been called
down through the centuries
our Christ
likeness in other words
how deeply we embody
the radiant love
of the God we've come to know
in Jesus
so am I saying that
big things are bad
that being an outward success is bad
that scorecard number one is evil
no no I'm not saying that
in fact you may even find
that getting your internal world
properly oriented
heck that might even help you externally
so no I'm not
saying that being a big person doing big things
in big places or something
that's somehow inherently bad
what I'm saying is
don't obsess
there
instead
focus here
focus on the second
scorecard because when we
embrace that switch
then we can begin
to embrace simply
being
us
like that's
that's the greatest thing to be
ourselves
isn't it amazing how we spend our
whole lives trying
to be comfortable
being
us
and let's be honest
most of us are
pretty invisible
like all things considered
we're very tiny people in the world
and most of us work
in relative obscurity
doing quiet and
mostly unseen things
but God
sees
God sees your spouse
your friends, your co-workers
your kids
they see
they know how you are doing
on your internal scorecard
and perhaps most importantly of all
you see
you know
so I'll close with this
Dr. Lair he also does an exercise
with people where he
says you have 30 minutes
five words
choose the five words you would want
on your tombstone
go and he said
it's absolutely remarkable because
no one ever chooses
words that
align with the externally
focused scorecard number one
no one ever says
okay five words
CEO
or
world champion
number one in sales
what words do they
choose
it's always character words
and relational words
integrity
faithful
friend
kind
courageous
so although the whole
culture is just
pushing you
pushing I mean especially
through advertising
there's so much social pressure
just to try to get you to
obsess with who
you are on the outside
don't do it
don't give in
obey Christ
keep your focus
within
because that's the scorecard
that really matters
let me pray for you
Lord Jesus
we want to
we want to live focused
intentional
meaningful beautiful
Christ like lives
that's what we want to do
we don't want a Christianity
that's just a bunch of
outward rituals
that somehow don't
produce actual transformation
God we want to be
like you full of grace
and kindness and
truth and goodness
when people interact with us
we want them
to just get the sense
that they've
been with someone who loves
them really well
God we want to thrive
in our second scorecard
and so God right now in our
divine moment
God hear our prayer
that we want to thrive on our second
scorecard and when we
become
when we get pulled out of our
minds when we get pulled
into the ways of the world God and we start
to obsess and worry about
scorecard number one would you
just bring us back to what matters
God remind us
by your spirit
and we love you
thank you for your faithfulness to us
in the powerful name of Jesus I pray
Amen
don't be discouraged
oh I realize
it's hard to take
courage in a world
full of people
you can lose sight
of it all in the
darkness inside you
can make you feel
small
show me a
smile
don't be
unhappy
can't remember when
I last
saw you laughing
if this world makes you
crazy and you've
taken all you can
bear just
call me up cause I
will always be there
I see your true
color
shining blue
I see your true
colors
and that's why
I love you
so don't be afraid
to let
them show
your true colors
true
colors
are beautiful
I see your true
colors
shining blue
I see your true
colors
and that's why I
love you
so don't be afraid
to let them
show
your true
colors
true
colors are
beautiful
like a
rainbow
oh like
a rainbow
Huzzah!
Thanks
Mithy and Mel
I love that
song
Is it originally from the movie Trolls?
I think. I don't know if it was originally from there
but that was beautiful
and thank you
all for joining us so much
and we hope
that we can continue to connect with you
in other ways throughout the week that are significant
and meaningful
if you have a need, please do not
hesitate to reach out
you can send us a Facebook message
or you can email us at the table TX
you can go on our website
and get more information
on meetups who meet
throughout the week
and
connect either virtually
or some of them try to get
some in-person meetings as well
but please don't hesitate
to let this reach beyond the Sunday
evening slot
if you need community
or friendship or a listening ear
we want to be there for you
another great way to connect
we're so excited to say
that after taking last
month off with the holidays and everything
our book club is back at it
and we'll be meeting for the first time this
year February the 6th
that's a
Saturday morning. We're going to meet virtually
this month
or next month but
this time around we're going to meet virtually
and you can get the link
for that but you can
either comment below
and Sarah
who is one of the leaders of the book
club also Glenda Bayron is one of the
leaders of that book club
she shared a couple weeks ago here
her story so
those ladies will reach out to you
but you can comment here below
you could also
email Sarah
which is S-A-R-A
at the table T-X dot org
so
feel free to use one of those methods
to reach out and get more information
I believe she's not only going to post
the links for that but as well
she will post the link
for the book that they are going to be
reading for this month it is called
The Vanishing Half
and I heard from her earlier
that she's already read the first half and said
it's really good so
join us we would love to
have you there
all people are welcome
and
on that note I'm going to
send you out I was going to say
with a benediction but this is more
of a blessing as Brett was sharing
I could not help but thinking
of
what Jesus spoke in the words in Matthew
5 about
those who are blessed
so I'm going to go ahead and actually
read this from
the NIV
this is Matthew chapter 5
it says
blessed are the poor in spirit
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
blessed
are those who mourn
for they will be comforted
blessed are the meek
for they will inherit the earth
blessed are those
who hunger and thirst for righteousness
for they will be filled
blessed are the
merciful for they will be shown
mercy
blessed are the
pure in heart for they
will see God
blessed are the peacemakers
for they will be called sons of God
blessed
are those who are persecuted because of
righteousness for theirs is the
kingdom of heaven
and blessed are you
when people insult you or
persecute you and falsely say all kinds
of evil against you because of me
rejoice and be
glad because great is your reward in
heaven
may you have a blessed week
and find yourself in the category
of people who are able to
see and find God
even in the midst of hard times
or obscurity or
smallness
we love you, we are with you
and behind you
good night
you